all right here we go
all right one minute past ten welcome
everybody hope you're all well
um yep welcome to this this morning's um
audit squishy committee um wednesday
24th of march
do we have any apologies for absence
uh apologies from councillor malone
chair
okay thank you very much um minutes of
previous meeting
uh people happy with those and happy
that um to approve them and sign and for
me to sign them
and any objections to that then we have
people okay i think we're okay for that
yes
thank you yep um item three any
declarations of interest
no okay any public questions
nope one day we'll have loads it'd be
great
um item five any member questions
no no member questions okay in that case
we'll go straight to item six the
internal audit report
um and that's the audit manager welcome
sue
thank you chair and good morning
everybody um this report is if you're
following the agenda pack on the
internet this starts at page five in the
pack
and it's just a short report from me
it's the internal audit update
just to show what audits have been
completed recently
and it's very much continuing the theme
from december
um in that we've been largely busy with
more grants
um as the various lockdown grants are
released we we get involved and we look
at them make sure the controls are in
place and
and test check them um so um
in addition to that we've done some of
the bread and butter core systems work
namely the main accounting and the
payroll audit
um payroll has been completed and is at
draft report stage and we have a debrief
with the auditors this afternoon
and main accounting is largely complete
so even though it's a a fairly reduced
plan this year due to
the covert grants of the main core
system
financial audits and the main accounting
and the payroll are probably the ones
that we would want to see completed most
and these can be shared with external
audits as well in case that helps with
their final accounts work
so the table on page five sorry page six
shows you where we are with the audit
work um and the plan that was brought to
uh members in march uh last year
and in addition to that i just wanted to
add some of the other things we're
working on we're just about to start
this year's governance review
um because as members will recall you
will be required to look at the
annual governance statement at the next
meeting so
we're doing a lot of background work in
preparation for that
and part of that involves gathering
assurance from all service managers as
well to feed into both
my annual audit opinion and for
yourselves for the
for the annual governance statement um
we're doing
work on fraud as well counter fraud
we've received the results of the
national fraud initiative now
the national data matching exercise and
we're working through those
um to identify any fraud or error mainly
in the council tax benefits
and our creditor systems it um
it also looks at um housing tenancy
fraud
it looks at the um devon home choice um
waiting list and matches that to other
sources of data
and new for this year will be the covid
grants so that's an
another significant piece of assurance
we get over
having paid the covert grants correctly
um so the investigation of those matches
uh
in progress at this present time
and a fraud risk analysis um we maintain
a risk analysis for
all services within the council to show
where the potential frauds are
and what mitigations are in place to
counter them and
this is about to be shared and refreshed
with the management team just to raise
awareness
and ensure that um we're on top of
counter fraud
controls and corruption across all all
council services
um so again these aren't areas that are
actually listed in the report
but it's just background work that's
ongoing um
so we will be on target tuition a annual
opinion
in the usual way at the next meeting um
it will be uh slightly different in that
it will call on other sources of
assurance
to supplement the audit work that's been
done but that may be made very clear
in the report that's brought you to the
next meeting and
happy to take any questions thank you
okay thank you sue um yeah a difficult
year and i think well done
to everybody involved thank you does
anybody have any questions for students
um yeah you're happy where you
do you want us to raise our hands or do
we just keep on off mute and
just come in with a small committee well
i can i can see you all so if you want
to just raise your
your visual hand that's probably quicker
so if you go chris
first chris and then bill yeah yeah i
was just going to ask you you're happy
with
where you actually are are you you've
done nine good one excellent and you've
got still got ten to do
are you do you feel you're up to speed
and got plenty of time or are you
struggling or
what have you yes it's a good question
chris because
obviously there is less audits um
completed this year and it has been a
unique year
um and
what this doesn't capture is the
assurance i'm able to draw from
other sources um in the council that
um i'm involved in various groups and
um uh you know i think just by virtue of
being internal audit as well you know
i'm involved in
a lot of areas that um i can see for
example the council's
recovery planning the corporate
management team the it
requirements board they're all um
controlled if you like that are
happening
to to contribute to um good governance
so um i think collectively when you look
at the bigger picture and bring all that
together which we will do for the annual
report
um we are on track in terms of the
individual audits
the creditors the council tax and the
housing finance audits haven't been
completed
but we're going to prioritize those
through april and may
at the beginning of the new audit plan
and we're just looking at how we're
going to resource that now
um in terms of going forward to make
sure that
next year audits are delivered
on time by the end of the year this year
has been slightly unique
um but next year you know we're looking
to
um possibly increase resources to to
make sure that we can
deliver everything that's required but
personally i i do feel comfortable with
what's been achieved and
certainly happy that we've given the
attention we have done to the covid
grants because
that was a key requirement of government
that we did that and
um the the bays are just reviewing
um councils fraud assurance plans at the
moment and i'm aware that some councils
have been followed up
um you know for additional information
where bays consider they haven't done
enough so
thankfully touchwood we haven't been
contacted yet so i'm hoping that the
effort we've put into that
has stood us in good stead in that
respect so yes personally i'm
i'm i'm happy even though there's a
couple of gaps there
um i'm confident we will fill those soon
in order to deliver the annual opinion
thank you thank you thanks um bill you
had a question
good morning everyone yes good morning
and yes sir i can obviously imagine how
hard work it's been for the last year i
can
and it must be incredible to try to cope
with it all my my question is
i don't seem to have got any actual
reports for internal audits for quite a
while now
um they've been completed
maybe i'm not accessing right but i i i
can't see any since christmas as far as
i can see but
other people might um have received some
or whatever
but um now if we could get some that
would be
wonderful with regard to the culvert
grants and things
um you know frightened me this morning
just to see 36.1 million whether it was
fraud nationwide or whatever it is
agreed i think that's probably a great
understatement but
um situation with it is is yes we're
doing
and obviously paying to the right people
as far as possible we check for fraud as
we go out
but then you know serious crime might
well be involved with this sort of stuff
which are very convincing if in fact
additional fraud is found in the future
are we responsible for having paid it
erroneously or would it be something
greater that might take responsibility
for the amount of money that's been lost
through it or whatever
yes that's a very good point uh bill um
we the onus is on us if grant has been
paid
incorrectly because um i mean that's not
brand everybody's a fraudster
you know we have had a couple just
through um you know
possible misunderstanding that have been
claimed when they shouldn't have done so
it can just be pure error as well an
error on our part
so where one has been identified um
the onus is on us to put recovery
measures in place as we would any other
debt
so we would raise a debtor account for
that and pursue the recovery of the
monies ourselves
um i will check what would happen i mean
thankfully
in terms of team bridge um the fraud and
error level has been very low
and i think of the the two significant
ones i can think of one actually repaid
as soon as it was
um highlighted and one's repaying um
gradually um by installment so um
the onus is definitely on us to recover
in the first instance
what would happen if that
wasn't successful i will check and get
back to you
um don't off the top of my head all
right
that's a really good question because
this is uncharted territory and we're
not going to know
for quite some time how we might have
been impacted by
by this kind of fraud and as you say
very very little of it in team bridge so
far we're very lucky i think
yes and the national ford initiative
will be very telling because
um that's not what we don't have we've
checked everything within our power that
we could do that we have access to so
you know whether it's a bona fide rate
payer we've used what they call a
spotlight tool which
helps you check with companies house
that it is a registered business
but the one thing we can't do is easily
check with other authorities because one
of the conditions is that they're not
supposed to um
claim if if the amounts given to them
are going to take them over the state
aid limit
but of course we have no way whatsoever
of checking that without knowing what
they might have
received elsewhere whereas the nfi the
national ford initiative that will do
so we're we're keenly looking forward to
seeing what um
results come back from that just to um
and that's like the missing bit of the
jigsaw for us
and and we've you know we'll be ready to
attack those matches when we get them
um just to see you know that that once
the
nfi is completed it's very unlikely that
anything else will be
discovered in terms of fraud um you know
we've got our whistle blowing lines out
there if
a member of the public or another
business wanted to raise an alert we've
we've done our own checks
so the nfi is just the last piece of the
jigsaw really
and then we should have a true picture
of um whether we've any more frauds out
there
thank you thanks a lot thank you very
much that's good does anybody have
um any more questions for say
no we're fine thank you very much sue
are we happy to note that report
everybody happy yeah i just have a
proposal on secondary sorry for that um
i propose that we note it do i have a
second lin
that's the government bradley thank you
very much that's great we'll know that
report thank you sue
for that um okay item
seven which is page nine on your agenda
pack
um financial instructions and contract
procedure rules waiver report
thank you chair yes that's me again um
so
this routine monitoring reports to tell
you what
which waivers have gone through since
the last meeting there's three on there
um low carbon study for the local plan
direct appointment
to update the low carbon evidence that's
required for that
future high streets work um we had to
remodel our bid
for a lesser amount so we had to um
reappoint hatch generous to do that for
us
and lastly the district heating project
for southwest exeter
um it's our due diligence on um
checking the costings and savings
assumptions
um and that was funded by bayes um
so just the three waivers um actually
one's come in
since i wrote this report but we'll
carry that one forward to the
um the next meeting that's purchased of
a tractor for the
rangers at um uh dornish warren um
since they have for those watching and
not in the know what's bay's
ah yes um that's i have to think myself
actually it's the department for
business energy
and industrial strategy so it's it's the
arm of the government that
um give us the majority of the funding
for anything business related
so bays have overseen the kobe grants
and
quite a lot of the high street and
business regeneration projects
brilliant thank you thank you very much
does anybody have any questions on on
that report
okay are we happy to note i propose that
we note that report do i have a
secondary
councillor rolison thank you okay that's
uh item seven noted thank you very much
uh item eight sorry did someone say
someone
no um itemate um annual audit letter
julie hi how are you i'm very well how
are you all doing
yeah thank you very much indeed um
before before i go into our um i think
we've got the next couple of items on
the agenda before i sort of go into
those
um i just want to take the opportunity
to introduce uh your new audit manager
um gail i don't know if gayle can give a
wave and are you a little bit dark in
the
in the photos there but um just just we
do talk about it in our progress report
later in the agenda but
um just to sort of introduce to the
committee why we make that change
um and a lot of this is linked to some
of our internal rotation requirements
that are needed within within
um the the audit team um and that's
partly linked to
um independence requirements so as to
make sure that we fulfill
our independence requirements in
accordance with ethical standards
we have to routinely rotate both our
managers
and our engagement leads across our
audits
and whilst team bridge wasn't
necessarily due for a rotation
because of rotation requirements and
some of the other audits in our
portfolio
as a result of just shifting some of
those around we've had to
realign some of our portfolios for some
of our managers so
um so effectively gail um turner
radcliff has now come in as your new
audit manager to
to replace um to replace andy
um andy davis um gail brings
a wealth of local government experience
and i work a lot
closely with gail on on a number of
audits um in the past so
um i'm sure she's very much looking
forward to to working with you but i
don't know gayle if you just want to say
a very brief high and then i'll go
specifically into the agenda
sorry i couldn't find the unmoved button
then so yes so my name's gail as julie
said
i've been working as a manager in grand
theft auto now for
quite a few years so i've got a couple
years of
public sector behind me and i have been
working closely with julie um
and some of the other engagement leads
as well so
look forward to working with you all
thank you gail
um so in terms of the the item on the
agenda item eight um is the annual audit
letter so the annual audit letter is
effectively what brings
the 2019-20 audit year to a close so
there's nothing new in terms of new
findings or new information in the
annual audit letter
it is effectively meant to be a sort of
a public a more public-facing summary
of all of the audit activity that has
previously come before this committee
um in previous meetings um obviously the
the bulk of our work is around the work
we do with the accounts and also a value
family conclusion which was presented
to the audit scrutiny committee back in
october and then
the final position went to full council
at the end of november so
this is effectively just just a summary
of that so i wasn't proposing chair to
go through that in any detail but i'm
happy to take any
any questions if there are any okay does
anybody have any questions for julie
on it's stuff that we've already
discussed it's
summarized nope i think we're fine thank
you julie
thank you very much should i move
straight on to item nine then chair
yes that would be great yeah do we need
to to note that yeah
sorry
thank you thank you very much yeah
straight on to number nine thank you
so so now we've closed off 1920 our
focus has now obviously shifted to
preparations and planning for for 2021
um and so um this progress report um
it's in the usual format it just gives
you an update as to where we are with
things but there are a couple of
specific areas just for me to to draw to
your attention within that progress
report
um within um if i refer to page
um sorry it's page number it's page five
of our report which is page 35 of of
your papers
um it does pick up on some other areas
of work in addition to the main accounts
and value for money work that we
undertake
and that relates to the work we do on
the certification
of claims and returns and specifically
for this authority
is the the audit of the housing benefit
return that goes to the department
for working pensions um so so that work
um has now been concluded um so
not in a normal year um that work has to
be concluded by the end of november but
obviously with
the additional issues around lockdown
and and
and covert this year the the drp did
extend that deadline
um to the to the end of january um to to
conclude that
conclude that work so we summarize there
um
the the key findings from that um it's
not unusual
to find um errors um in the in in
in the testing that we do within housing
benefits um this this council is in
is by no means an outlier if you think
about the level of precision with these
claims in terms of
reviewing entitlements checking
calculations etcetera
um it's very very rare that you get a
council that is completely clean
of errors unfortunately because of the
methodology that the dlp requires to
follow
if you find an error of whatever
magnitude whether it be a couple of
pence or a couple of pounds or
something more significant you have to
follow what they call their 40 plus
methodology which effectively means
for every error for that nature of area
you have to test 40 additional cases
to to be able to determine the extent of
that error across the whole of the
um the caseload to which that error
relates so it is quite an extensive
amount of testing um so i just want to
make sure that
even though there is errors reported
that members see that in the context of
of the work that we have to do in in in
that area
so um we've highlighted that just so
some
some some items that that were
identified on that
um obviously i've talked to you about
the change of the engagement team
with with gail coming in and so that the
main part of our progress report then is
on page 34 of your papers which is then
talking about
where we are with the risk assessment
process for 2021.
so moving specifically onto the
financial statements audit side of
things
for the moment um they're not a huge
amount of changes this year in terms of
the actual code that governs
how your accounts pull together so um
i'm sure your finance officers
are pleased that there's no major sort
of technical changes as such to
have to contend with the account so um
we're starting our sort of planning and
risk assessment work at the moment
and indeed you'll see for the item uh
that's next in the agenda
that actually shows you some of the
initial risk assessment that we are
considering
and engaging with both management and
those charged with governance
to inform that risk assessment um
one of the big areas of change that you
will see as a committee this year is in
the value for money work
so there's a new code come in from the
first of april last year
issued by the national audit office and
that has changed the framework in which
we undertake our value for money work
for 2021.
so as you'll see from the annual audit
letter in the previous gender item
in previous years alongside the opinion
we give on the accounts we've given a
separate opinion
on your value for many arrangements and
the new code framework that binary
conclusion of qualified unqualified as
far as your vfm is concerned that has
now gone
and and what the the the neo's
requirements now have sort of
moved towards is a much broader
narrative um around
uh your arrangements across the
organization so
where in previous vfm assessments we've
done our risk assessment
we've identified particular risks and we
have focused
exclusively on those risk areas and then
reported by exception if there are any
issues
this new vfm framework is much broader
in scope in that
it looks at three sort of key key areas
key themes
around your financial sustainability and
medium term financial planning
around the governance arrangements for
the council as a whole
and then around your arrangements for
insuring um
value for money economy efficiency and
effectiveness in in how you
deliver value for money and within that
there are specific criteria that we're
required to look at
as part of that assessment and then when
we conclude
on that we don't give an opinion but we
will come to you with a separate report
at the end of the year at the same time
that we give you your opinion on the
accounts
and we will present that in what we call
an annual auditor's report
so there's a new reporting requirement
to
report our final vfm findings and that
will just be a report by exception
it will be a report that actually gives
you lots of positive assurances as well
about the things that you're doing well
as well as the things that
we would consider any council needs to
improve
um if you move on to um page
let me find the page again um so if you
move on to page 40 of your papers which
is page 10 of our report
um you'll actually see in there a bit
more of an information about
what it will be included in that
auditor's um annual report
but also then specifically how we will
then present recommendations
so the new vfm code brings in this this
concept this definition of um
significant weaknesses so whilst we will
not be qualifying
an audit opinion uh if we found
something wrong
we have the ability within this new
framework to
identify where we consider there are
significant weaknesses
in an authority and then any
areas where we think there will be a
significant weakness in those
arrangements we are required to issue
what we call a key recommendation
a key recommendation is required in any
instance where we've identified a
significant weakness
you can see from that that table that
there is also an opportunity to issue
uh sort of a lower grade of
recommendation called an improvement
recommendation
and that's generally just given an
opportunity for added value where we
think this this
scope for the authority to improve its
arrangements but it doesn't have the
same sort of status
as as a key recommendation and then in
terms of statutory recommendations those
will only ever be used in
exceptional circumstances and this
specific statutory legislation about
how those recommendations will need to
be dealt with and responded to
in a public council meeting so there was
only those powers would only ever be
used in in sort of exceptional
circumstances
but at least kind of gives you a sort of
an idea as to how the
um the the reporting arrangements will
change and
under the under the new vfm code um
so so chair i i'll leave it at that
moment just in terms of
uh sort of an intro but i'd be very
happy to take any questions i know
that's a lot to sort of take in a very
sort of
condensed sort of presentation yeah no
no
it is a lot and it's interesting to see
the changes um
uh i i mean i've just got a couple of
comments i know i know we sort of said
the 40 plus methodology you know if you
found a few pence
uh difference then then you know you've
got to go through 40
plus cases well the end of the day it's
public money so we've got to make sure
we get it right haven't we
um and with so much
new detail in in this report you know
we've been extended until
january uh is it does it look like we're
on track for
getting that done so so that is already
complete so it's that was january as in
january just passed
that's all been completed and and
submitted now so that that that's
already been submitted to gwp so that
worked for
for 1920s sure has now been concluded
okay
done right okay thank you um okay uh
questions bill first and then chris
julie that was um very very um detailed
really
my my sort of thing is with these new
approaches to value for money
is you say there might be significant
weaknesses i'm trying to
imagine what a weakness might be or what
it might look like what
what you might have actually seen and
noticed and then
make recommendations about that's the
thing sure of course i mean
if we were to look at the example of um
financial resilience so if we looked at
that pillar for example
um you know an example of that would be
um a
a council that had inadequate um
monitoring arrangements in place to
monitor
its its budget and financial position
or an authority that had set a savings
plan
um but actually um the savings that
they'd set weren't realistic
or didn't have any sort of um detailed
informed business cases behind it it's
just kind of a
sort of finger in the air we think we're
going to save this amount on on
x it needs to be much more informed on
that so um
that could be just just one example of
what could be a significant weakness
um you know on things like um governance
um you know if you didn't have you know
appropriate governance structures in
place
to um consider sort of uh key decisions
and and reports on particular areas that
could be
you know an example of of a governance
failing
so you know the sorts of things you know
if we were looking at you know some of
the work that internal audit does for
example
you know if you had you know a an area
of
of the council's governance where
they've raised some
significant internal control weaknesses
you know we would have to have a look at
that and take a view as to
whether that um that is is is is
isolated enough or is it quite
significant in terms of the strategic
impact that that control weakness has
across the organization so
it is very much a judgmental um a
judgmental
view and and within the firm we will
have
moderation processes that we will carry
out across all of our local authorities
to make sure that anything that we are
designating in that sort of significant
weakness character category
that there is kind of consistency in in
the way that we're applying that across
different organizations so that we're
not being unduly harsh
or generous from from one authority to
another
just just on that the value for money
this is
and it because those points are
obviously come up under the other terms
of the order as well with problems with
governance and all that sort of stuff
are they too close together now value
for money and the
ordinary or hold it report or are they
still
very separate they are quite
they are quite separate well i suppose
there is a little bit of crossover so
if we looked at the council's
arrangements for how you prepare your
account
so your financial processes your
financial controls
um uh in terms of the you know the
timeliness of your reporting
etc now there is some crossover there in
terms
of governance because governance is very
much concerned around
the internal control framework of the
authority so there will be some read
across to that
if you had good arrangements in place
for preparing your accounts that would
normally suggest that you don't have any
risk of significant weakness as far as
the governance side of things is
concerned
um but in terms of the way that the the
new framework is structured
they're very much trying to sort of
detach the vfm as much as possible from
from the account side of israel now that
which is why we now have that sort of
dual reporting
so whilst there will be consideration
and reference to um
you know the the two aspects being the
account in the vfm work
um effectively they can be run as two
separate processes
as far as our work is concerned okay
thanks very much for that thank you
chris
yeah hello julie uh i just i haven't
heard one of these terms before
with regard to the housing benefit on
page five
you quoted uh this enabled us to agree a
sell
amendment of 149 pounds 69. what what's
what in what context is a sell agreement
is this sort of some
sort of invoice where there was a
supplementary
voice tacked on and it failed to be paid
or
you know in this i know it's about
housing benefit
but um what what is this
149 61 in the context of
your report yes uh thanks for the
question councillor so
effectively the return that the
authority prepares
and sends the dwp um that return it goes
over about a dozen
pages from recollection and each um
there's a number of boxes what we're
referring to is cells
in this case so each box will have a
cell reference number so
cell one through two i can't remember
the final number girl i don't think
it's say 150 there's various number
sales
and that will capture lots of different
financial data
about um the types of housing benefit
expenditure that the authorities
incurred over the course of the year
it will break down things like um
the levels of um benefit that has been
overpaid to different claimants and then
and this categorization of those
overpayments um
as to whether it was um overpayments
that
um that the claimant had failed tell you
about quickly enough
or whether there was um delay in
processing overpayments in terms of the
authority
had received the information but just
took a bit of time to to process them
depending on the classification of all
those different overpayments that will
attract different levels of subsidy
to to the authority so that's why it's
broken down into lots of different
details so
effectively um for for this particular
item we're effectively saying one of
those cells had to be adjusted
by by 149 pounds which was adjusted by
the authority before they resubmitted
their return to the dwp
does that help that sort of answers my
question
in a very technical way
it's all very technical we'll be giving
we'll be giving back 140 now
we will be paying it extra i knew you
could ask
i can't remember which way it was
but i
sometimes i think i live in to the real
world
too much thank you no problem
have we got any more um questions on on
that
item for julie no
that's great um thank you thank you um
are we happy to note that
item i'm i'm happy to propose it
mary's a second it thank you thanks to
cochlear lovely thank you
okay my goodness item 10
um already thank you very much so as i
said i sort of kind of it started to
introduce this
uh um as past the last item and so we're
just trying to formalize
a lot more of what we're doing at the
risk assessment stage um with the
authority
um and one of the things that is
changing as part of the
requirements for the accounts this year
whilst there's not huge amount of
changes
from the council side in terms of you've
not got a whole load of new accounting
requirements to worry about
there are actually quite a lot of
changes happening from the audit side in
terms of
whilst the authority has to pay the
accounts to accounting standards we have
to award it
to um auditing standards that are issued
by the financial reporting council
and there's a new autism standard that
has come in for this year's audit
that talks all around um the uh
the around estimates and any estimation
that's required by the authorities part
of its preparation
of the accounts um there was a slide in
the previous progress report that talks
a little in a little more detail around
that if anybody wanted some further
information
and so what we want to make sure is that
we're engaging in the right way at the
right time now with both management
and those charged with governance to
make sure that they
in accordance with these new
considerations under this under these
new auditing standards
to make sure that you're having the
ability to inform um
our risk assessment as we start to plan
the audit for this year
um i appreciate the nature of this
document is quite technical because it
asks us to consider the different
estimates and compliance with laws and
regulations
consideration around fraud etc etc these
are all requirements that are laid out
to us as part of our
requirements of the auditing standards
so
effectively what we've done is we've
provided this uh document to the
authority and and
um both your section one five one
officer and
um and your audit manager has has
provided some input
to this document and is put before this
committee for your consideration so
i think really what we're looking for um
from from you as members
is do you recognize the comments that
officers are are making
do you do support those are there any
additional comments from your
perspective
that you wish to to add to that before
we effectively pull together our our
final risk assessment for for this
year's
this year's work so i'll leave it that
cheap i don't know if see if there's
anything else you wanted to add to that
in terms of
your contributions to it
no thank you julie um nothing particular
to add
but as julie said there's a lot of
information to take in there so
even if not at this meeting if if
members want to come back to me
afterwards to query anything in the
boxes
please feel free and regarding the
frauds
um what i could do is share with you the
fraud risk analysis that i've mentioned
both in here and in my report earlier
um because again that will give you an
overview of the sorts of fraud we
consider across the council might help
as well
but um more than happy to engage with
any members over the content of this
even if not now you know a later date
thank you
yeah i was going to say that there's
there's quite a lot there to get your
head around and and i think you know
we need to think i did have to to smile
to myself but
page 54 the very first question what do
you regard as the key events or issues
that will have a significant impact on
financial statements for 2021
covert 19 nothing else
um you know that's just had such a
significant impact on all of us hasn't
it and
you know particularly on this so um
yeah does anybody have else have any
more questions chris
well i would just say yeah on that i'm
not really sure that i've
qualified enough to be able to put any
input into it really it's not i think
it's asking quite a lot of us
as counselors to comment on the rights
and the wrong sort of thing
on this one but i don't know what other
members think
it's almost maybe worth putting out to
to the wider membership of the council
um where there might be some different
kind of expertise
um i mean obviously this will go to the
executive or the executive will have
eyes on it
um but yeah i agree with you there's a
hell of a lot there um
and you know i'm not sure some of us are
qualified to
to um make comments or make judgments on
it but
um that's an interesting point sorry sue
and one um one one way you could
approach it is is
just to view it as when you read through
is there anything that the audit
committee are aware of that's not
commensurate with what's written here
i mean that's possibly a very simplified
way of looking at it when you read it if
something
rings about us well they say they do
that but you know
that's not what they told us last month
and um or any other knowledge you you
know just is it commensurate with
what you as members have heard at audit
committee
um or you know out of audit committee
throughout the years
um but it's just a bit of a comparison
really that could be a way of doing it
that's really useful thank you it just
just clarifies it yeah thank you for
that thank you very much does anybody
else have any more questions on on item
10 on this is you know it's
quite a significant report
no no my goodness
[Laughter]
well um record time i think
oh before we are we happy to note that
report i'm happy to propose it
um do you have a seconder yeah uh
councillor
goodman bradbury um well i think i think
that's a record that's 39 minutes 10 39.
that must be right the last one was for
um
10 foot 10 45 45 minutes so i think
we've broken our record
um however this was a fairly a fairly
simple agenda it was
the usual things that we do every year
it's it's july that people are going to
need to brace themselves for because i
think that's going to be a bit of a
bit of a longer uh a haul there so um
but thank you everybody and you know
obviously have a look through that item
10 again and and with the advice that
sue's given us i think that would be
worth
worth looking at um in more detail um
and i shall obviously mention it to um
the executive
members as well um but uh no thank you
very much does anybody else have any
comments before we go julie
yes james it was just really to say that
if if any members do have any um
subsequent comments
um that they'd like to sort of feed
through to us um you know please feel
free to to email those to
to either myself or or to gail or if you
want to put
sorry i don't want to nominate you but
sue if if if you're happy to collate any
um
to send them through that that would be
absolutely fine as well
yeah no thank you for that yeah i mean i
i you know personally i find sue
extremely helpful um and is always
willing at the end of the phone to
answer questions and queries so
you know obviously go through her go
through me and um
that's very very useful um so yes
so people are happy we've um noted
and proposed and seconded every item on
our agenda so
um oh chris sorry chris i can see you
halfway there
i'm just saying it's what's dropped off
the agendas it seems to be there so the
only third
um any future work program we used to
have
one or two as it these meetings some of
them tend to be quite short meetings as
this one's proved to be
yes and we we have had people come and
talk about
our insurance policy and this sort of
thing
yeah yeah i think i think we're aware of
that and
we know i think if this was normal times
we might be doing that
the extra curricular if you see what i
mean but i think because the teams are
are so stressed because of the current
situation we're trying to keep things
like that to a minimum but
we need to i'll accept i'll accept yeah
yeah but actually as a future work
program it would be useful to have that
maybe a little bit in
advance um christopher if that if that
would be okay because then people know
what to expect because
obviously this is a short one but july's
meeting is going to be a little bit
longer so
yeah useful for members i've actually
got a future work program
it's a bit light at the moment um okay
because i'm not 100 sure on what's
coming
at the moment i'll talk to a few people
afterwards and
see if we can get it maybe sent out to
councillors after this maybe
you wanted to see what was coming up
yeah thank you very much that yeah good
point chris that'll be useful thank you
very much
okay so if people are happy um i'm gonna
close the meeting thank you very much
thank you julie and
um gail for joining us um and thank you
all very much for all your work thank
yeah thank you all yeah take care
goodbye